what's going on everybody my name is
alex freeburg and today we're going to
be starting our intermediate sql series
if you joined us for our last series we
walked through the basics of sql which
is everything you needed just to get
started and in this series we're going
to be walking through some intermediate
concepts to really take your skills up
to the next level
all right now let's get rid of me
because we do not need to be seeing me
for the rest of the series at the very
top here are some of the things that
we're going to be going through today
which are inner joins and then outer
joins and in the outer joins we have a
few different styles a few different
types of outer joins
now a join is a way to combine multiple
tables into a single output
for now we're going to be using the
employee demographics and the employee
salary table so let's get a look at both
of these tables and see what's in them
in our employee demographics table we
have employee id first name last name
age and gender and then down here in our
employee salary table we have employee
id job title and salary
if you notice they have a similar column
and that's going to be the employee id
now when you're doing a join you have to
do this based off a similar column and
typically you want it to be a unique
field
so we're going to be using the employee
id from both tables to join these tables
together to create one output
so let's get rid of this real quick
and let's start building our query to
join these two tables together
so the first thing we're going to do is
an inner join so let's do select
everything
and let's do it from sql tutorial
dot dbo dot employee demographics
and let's do
join
we can also say inner join
but join by default is going to say
enter
and we're going to do sql tutorial dot
dbo dot
employee salary
now we have to join them together which
is what we talked about earlier we're
going to be doing that based off the
employee id
so for that we have to say on
and then we're going to say
employee
demographics
dot
employee id
is equal to employee
salary dot
employee id
so let's run this real quick
and take a look at the output
and let me pull this up real quick
so
what we are looking at is actually both
tables combined we have the employee id
first name last name age gender and then
here's the salary employee id job title
salary
now an inner join is really only going
to show everything that is the same
so in both tables there are employee ids
of one zero zero one
all the way down to one zero zero nine
but if you notice there is data that is
missing
real quick let's go down to this graphic
and let's look at this inner join
an inner join is going to show
everything that is common or overlapping
between table a and table b
so what we are looking at here is
exactly that we're only looking at the
things that are similar based off this
employee id
in both tables
now let's change this join
to a full
outer
join
and let's run this and see what we get
now if you notice the output is very
different
so let's take a look at it and see why
it's so different
if you notice everything down till here
is the exact same so employees 1001 down
to 1009 are exactly the same
but once we get down to row 10 it starts
to get very different
now we are joining these tables based
off the employee id so for example right
here ryan howard has an employee id of
1011.
but as you can see in this table for
salaries there is no 1011 employee id so
it has nothing to link it to so
because of that it fills in everything
as null because it has nothing to match
on this table and vice versa
in the employee salary table there's a
person in here that's a salesman and
there's no employee id at all which
means all this information is going to
be null
and we can see that in this diagram
right here so this is the full outer
join right here
and what it is saying is we are going to
show everything from table a and table b
regardless of if it has a match based on
what we were joining them on so even if
table a has an employee id but there's
no employee id in table b we're still
going to show it and vice versa
so now let's look at a left outer join
a left outer join is going to take the
left table
and say we want everything from the left
table and everything that's overlapping
but if it's only in the right table we
do not want it now what is the left and
the right table the left table is going
to be our first table that we use our
right table is going to be the second
table that we use so we're going to look
at everything in the employee
demographics table regardless of whether
or not it has a match on the employee id
in the employee salary table so this is
what that looks like
so as you can see this is our entire
table for employee demographics
and down here
we have three that have information in
the employee demographics table but have
absolutely no information
in any of the employees salary table
because there's nothing to match it on
so this 1011 is not in this table this
1013 is not in this table and this one
does not even have an employee id so
we're not going to have a match at all
and if we change that to the right
you'll see the exact opposite it's going
to show us everything in the employee
salary table so now we have all of our
information right here from the employee
salary table and if it doesn't match in
this table it's just going to have nulls
so down here we have 1010 and obviously
there's not going to be anything
associated with that because there's no
1010 in the employee demographics table
and for this one we have a salesman with
no employee id
and since there's no employee id to tie
it to this demographics table we're
going to have nothing and we can see
that in the diagram right here
so for the left outer join we're looking
at everything in table a which is our
demographics table
and in our right outer join we're
looking at everything at table b which
is our salary table
now let's pull this down a little bit
so so far we've only been using the
select star so we've been selecting
everything and i only did that just for
demonstration purposes but you most
likely would not be doing this when you
actually use these joins what you're
probably going to want to do is select
exactly what columns you want in your
output
so for example let's do
employee id
let's do
first name
last name
and let's do job title
and let's do salary
and let's try to run that really quick
and as you can see it is not going to
work
now why is that not working it's not
working because we have two fields one
in each of these tables and we have to
specify what employee id we want because
that is going to drastically change what
our output is
so we have an employee id in this table
and in this table which one do we want
to use
so for this demonstration let's use
employeedemographics.employee id
and let's actually just do
an inner join
because it's easier for
the output
now let's run this and see what we get
so as you can see we now have the
employee id
first name last name job title and
salary now we're doing this with an
inner join based off the employee id
from the employee demographics table but
if we use the employee salary table it
should give us the exact same output and
that's because we're using an inner join
and an inner join is only going to show
us everything that overlaps between both
tables
but now let's try
a right
outer join and let's run this
now we're using this employee id from
our employee salary table and since
we're doing a right outer join we're
going to get all the information from
our employee salary table and it does
not have to be in our left table which
is our employee demographics table so if
you look at the information down here
this 110 is in the employee salary table
but it's in this position
because that's what we're looking at in
our select statement
and then over here we have our salary
and since we have information right here
which is in our employee salary table
but there is no employee id our employee
id is null now let's change this to look
at the employee demographics employee id
and execute it
as you can see that 110 is gone
now we just have this information right
down here
and we didn't have the employee id for
either of these so it's going to show it
regardless and that's again because we
have a right outer join
and that's why we have no employee id
down here
now let's do
a
left outer join
and it's basically going to do the
opposite of what we just looked at
now we're looking at everything from our
left table regardless of if it's in our
right table
and so our left table is our employee
demographics table and we are looking at
our employee demographics id
so with the employee demographics id
it's going to show us the first name and
the last name which is everything in our
left table our employee demographics
table and since for these ids
or lack of ids it's just going to give
us nulls in all of these places
if i change it right up here to the
employee salary employee id
and i execute it
because we're showing everything from
our left table which is our employee
demographics table we are still going to
see our names
but since we're using the employee id
from our right table
now we're just going to have blanks in
this information and this information
now let's look at a use case for these
joins
let's say robert california is
pressuring michael scott to meet his
quarterly quota and michael scott is
almost there he needs like a thousand
more dollars and he comes up with the
genius idea to deduct pay for the
highest paid employee at his branch
besides himself
so how does he go about doing this and
identifying the person that makes the
most money well of course he's going to
come to sql first
so we actually want to look at a full
outer join real quick
and
let's just look at everything
so here's what we have
we have the employee id first name last
name age gender employee id job title
and salary now what information do we
need to know
to get the information that michael
scott needs well we need the employee id
we want the first name and last name so
let's write all that real quick
so employee id
we need first name
we need
last name
and then we're also going to need the
salary
because we need to know who is the
highest paid employee
so now let's do an inner join because we
really only want to look at the employee
ids where we know what their name is and
their salary is and let's do this based
off the employee demographics table
really doesn't matter for an interjoin
but let's do that real quick so let's
look at this
so we have our employee id we have our
first name our last name and our salary
and we want to do it where it's not
michael scott and that's because michael
doesn't want to take away his own money
he wants to take away his employees
money so let's do where
first name
does not equal
michael and he knows that he's the only
one that is not named michael so now we
have our list
and let's do
order by
and
let's do
salary
and let's execute this
and let's do
descending so that we can get at the
very top
and this is tough tough news for dwight
schrute because it looks like he is the
highest paid employee besides michael
and so it looks like he is going to get
a cut in his pay this quarter so that
michael can meet his quota so that's
just one use case let's look at one more
use case let's start out by getting rid
of this
and looking at everything again
so for our next use case kevin malone
who is an accountant thinks that he may
have made a mistake when looking at the
average salary for our salesman
now angela martin is very good at sql
and so what she is going to do
is she wants to go in and calculate the
average salary for our salesman so
let's try to get that information
so all we're going to need is the job
title and the salary
so let's come up here
and let's get job title
and let's get salary
and let's look at this
and now we only want to look at
where the job title
is equal
to salesman
now the very last thing we want to do is
we want to say
we want the average
of salary
now since we're going to need to do a
group by we're going to have to get rid
of this salary
and just take job title right down here
and do group by
job title so we're going to have job
title and then the average salary
and there you go we have the salesman
and the average salary is 52 000 so
angela now knows to go back and fix what
kevin made a mistake on
and i thought it was appropriate to look
at unions next because unions and joins
are somewhat similar or closely related
and that's because in both instances
they're combining two tables to create
one output now what's the difference the
difference is that a join combines both
tables based off a common column
and in last video that was the employee
id so in both tables we had an employee
id
and when you're selecting your data you
have to choose either to only select one
employee id or you can choose both
employee ids but they're in separate
columns
and with a union you're actually able to
select all the data from both tables and
put it into one output where all the
data is in each column and not separated
out and you don't have to choose which
table you're choosing it from now that
may not have made 100 sense but let's
look at it real quick in stages
so let's go down here and let's actually
join this table together
and see what we get
now the two tables that we're looking at
is employee demographics and warehouse
employee demographics so over here we
have our employee demographics
information and then over here or
actually down here we have our warehouse
employee demographics
now right now i'm doing a full outer
join so we're looking at all the data
and if we were to pull this in to an
excel spreadsheet we could just copy
this and paste it over here and we would
be good to go and that's because we have
all the same columns first name last
name age gender first name last name age
gender but if we tried to combine this
in a query where we have this
information right here
it wouldn't work
we cannot get it in the same column and
that's where a union comes into play
so let's go back up here and let's
actually run
both of these
now as you can see
they have the exact same columns and
that makes it super easy for what we're
about to do all we're going to do
is between these two queries which are
completely separate right now all we're
going to do
is write union
so let's run
just this
now because of the union you can look
down here and the information that used
to be in the other table which were in
separate columns are now added down
below in the exact same order now daryl
philbin was actually in both tables and
the reason he isn't showing up multiple
times is because this union is actually
taking out and removing the duplicates
kind of like a distinct statement now
there's actually another thing called
union all and if we do union all it is
going to show us all of the information
regardless if it is a duplicate or not
so let's run that real quick and they
are both there but let's
order by
and let's do employee
id
so now let's run it
and as you can see right here these are
exact duplicates and so the union got
rid of it because they are the exact
same but the union all kept it in
because it is showing just the data as
is now let's get rid of this union all
because the only reason why it works so
well is because those two tables were
the exact same they were employee id
first name last name age gender so
they're basically the same tables just
with different information so it made it
really easy
but we have another table
employee
salary
and let's look at these two tables
so these two tables are obviously very
different they hold different
information
now we would still be able to combine
them so let's do
employee
id
first name
and
let's do age
now down here on the employee salary
table we will do employee id
job title and
salary
now
let's
use a union really quick
and run this one
and it is still going to work now why
does this work
well first off the reason it's working
is because these data types are the
exact same
or at least similar so text and text age
which is an integer salary which is an
integer it has the same amount of
columns so three
and three
so we have employee id
first name and age and it's taking that
from the first select statement and it's
still using a union to take the data
from the second select statement so it's
still inserting this information now
this is not what you want to do because
right here we have first name and it's
salesman salesman and in our age we have
30 45 000 and 45 000 is obviously not an
age so you want to be careful when
you're using a union to combine two
separate tables and make sure that the
data you're selecting is the same
a case statement allows you to specify a
condition and then it also allows you to
specify what you want returned when that
condition is met
so we're going to be using this employee
demographics table that we're looking at
right here we're going to walk through
the syntax of how to create a case
statement and then we're actually going
to some use cases at the end so let's
start off by specifying what columns we
want let's say we want the first name
we want the last name
and we want the age
now let's just get that information
now for our case statement we're going
to be using this h column so we actually
want the age to be in there so let's
specify
where age is not null
and run that so now we have a pretty
good look at it and let's just order by
h
just to clean it up a little bit
so now let's start building our case
statement so we're going to say case
and then we want to say when
now we need to specify what condition we
want to look for
so let's do when age
is greater than 30
then then what do we want to be returned
so we want to return that they are old
else so that means anything that is not
over the age of 30 we want to return
young
and then you need to specify that you
were done with the case statement and so
you will write
end at the very bottom
so this is our first case statement
let's run it and see what we get
so as you can see a new column was
created and if the person is over the
age of 30 so 31 and up they're given old
and if they're not over the age of 30
they are given
young now we can do as many when and
then statements as we want so if we want
to we can also do when the age
is between 27
and 30.
then we want to return young
and anyone else we're going to call a
baby
so now
we have ryan howard as the baby anyone
between 27 and 30 they're considered
young
and anyone over the age of 30 is old
now something to note is that the very
first condition that is met is going to
be returned so if there are multiple
conditions that meet the criteria only
the very first one is going to be
returned and let's demonstrate that real
quick
so if the age equals 38
then return
stanley because that is stanley
and let's execute this real quick
so right here i'm specifying that if
it's 38 it should return stanley but he
is right here and it still says old and
that's because this condition was
already met now if we were to put this
right here
it should work correctly
and let's try it out
so now because this condition is met
first it is going to return stanley down
here
so now let's get into our first use case
let's start off by copying this and
then
commenting it out
i only did that because i don't want to
rewrite it because i'm lazy
let's get rid of that and let's look at
this real quick we are going to join on
another table that we have
really fast
and that's going to be sql tutorial if
you've watched my other videos then you
know this table
and we're going to do that on
employee
demographics dot employee id
is equal to employee
salary dot employee id
okay
so let's just look at everything in
these tables really quick now we are
going to be focusing on the job title
and the salary column but we want their
first name and last name as well so
let's start building that out
let's do first name
last name
job title and salary
and let's look at this really quick so
now we have our employees and here is
the situation we had a fantastic year
this year selling paper and corporate
has allowed michael scott to give out a
yearly raise to every single employee
but not every employee is going to get
the same raise because our salesmen are
genuinely the people who made us our
money and they're going to get the
biggest raises while other people really
aren't going to get that big of a raise
so now let's go through and create a
case statement to calculate what their
salary will be after they get their
raise
so let's start off by saying case
and when
and we want it to say when job title is
equal to
salesman
so when they are a salesman what do we
want to happen so this is where the
calculation occurs so we're going to
take their salary
and then we're going to add
their salary
times how much their raise is going to
be so the salesman did really really
well and we want to give them a 10 raise
this year
now when
their job title is equal to
accountant
then and we'll take their salary
we will give them
let's give them a 5 raise still very
generous
there we go and
when
the job title
is equal to hr
then it's going to be the salary
plus the salary
times
and then we're going to do 0.231
all right and else
we're just going to do
salary
plus salary
oops
let's do parentheses
times and let's just give everyone else
a three percent raise and then we'll
write end
now let's take a look at our results
so here's what we have so far we have
our first name our last name our job
title and our salary that is our current
salary
and then we're going to have our salary
after we get our raise so i'm going to
actually write that up here so let's do
as
salary
after
raise
and let's execute that
so let's look at these raises really
quick so we have 45 000 and since he is
a salesman he gets a 10
raise which is a raise of four thousand
five hundred dollars so forty five
thousand plus four thousand five hundred
is forty nine thousand five hundred
dollars and as you can see down here we
have hr who is making fifty thousand
dollars and now he is making fifty
thousand dollars and five cents so
everybody got a raise
so that is our case statement i hope
that was helpful i find myself using the
case statement a lot when i'm wanting to
categorize things or label things and
that's kind of what we did in the first
example and you can even do calculations
like we did in this use case so i hope
that was helpful
now the having clause i feel a little
bit unappreciated in the sql community i
feel like it doesn't get a lot of love
and so today i want to describe how to
use it and what it's used for so before
we use the habit clause i want to set up
our query here
we want to use an aggregate function in
the group by statement and then i will
show you how to use this having clause
so let's look at the job title
and let's look at the count
of job titles
and then down here we need to do group
by
job title
and let's execute this
and here is our job titles and here's
the count of how many people have those
job titles so now let's say we want to
look at all the jobs that have more than
one person in that specific job
so let's do
where
the count
of job title
is greater oops is greater than one and
let's run that
and as you can see we're going to get
this message right here now let's read
it
an aggregate may not appear in the where
clause unless it is in a sub query
contained in a having clause or a select
list
and the column being aggregated is an
outer reference
what that is basically saying is we
cannot use this aggregate function in
the where statement we need to use a
having clause so let's get rid of this
and let's say having
the count of job title
greater than one i did the same thing
again
and let's execute this and we're still
going to get an error now why are we
getting that error
the reason is is because this having
statement is completely dependent on the
group by statement because we are
performing this after it has been
aggregated so this having statement
actually needs to go
after the group by statement because we
can't look at the aggregated information
before it's actually aggregated in that
group by statement so now let's run this
and it worked perfectly
so now we only have the jobs that have
more than one employee for that job
title
so now let's look at one more example
let's do the average let's say salary
and let's get rid of this having class
real quick
and just to look at this information
and let's do
order by and we'll do average
salary
so let's look at this and we have thirty
six thousand two sixty five thousand so
in the middle we got forty four thousand
five hundred so let's use this having
statement
and let's say
the average
of salary
where it is greater than
45 000. and we actually need to put this
right
here right after the group by and before
the order by
so let's run this and see what we get
and it works perfectly so now we're
looking at the job titles that have an
average salary of over forty five
thousand dollars
now what's the difference between
inserting data into a table and updating
data
insert into is going to create a new row
in your table well updating is going to
alter a pre-existing row while deleting
is going to specify what rows you want
to remove from your table so let's get
going with the updating so down here
holly flax does not have an employee id
age or gender now we want to update this
table to give her that information so
let's do update
now we need to specify what table we're
going to be hitting off of so let's do
sql tutorial
dot dbo dot employee demographics so now
we're going to use something called set
and set is going to specify what column
and what value you actually want to
insert into that cell
so let's set her
employee id equal to and it's going to
be 1012.
and we have to specify which one to do
this to because if we ran just this is
going to set every single employee id to
1012 because we haven't specified that
we only want hollyflax's row to be
updated so now we have to specify where
firstname
is equal to holly
and
last name
is equal to
flex
so now let's run this
and see what we get
so one row has been affected
let's
see what we got and there we go as you
can see the employee id was updated
exactly how we specified it right here
so we also want to update age and gender
and let's do that in the same query
so let's set the age equal to 31
and instead of using and we actually
need to use a comma so let's say age
equal to 31 comma
gender
is going to be equal to
female
and let's run this
and see what we get
there you go now let's look at our table
and as you can see it was updated to 31
and female
so very easy very easy to specify what
you want oftentimes
tables like this will have a unique key
like employee id is our unique key in
this table so i could easily just say
where the employee id
is equal to and then you know 1012.
so it's an easy way to specify what
employee you're trying to update so now
let's look at the delete statement the
delete statement is going to remove an
entire row from our table
so let's do delete
and we actually need to say from and we
have to specify what table we want to be
removing this information from so let's
do sql tutorial dot dbo dot employee
demographics
and now we need to specify what row we
want to remove so let's do where
employee id is equal to and let's use a
completely random employee id 1005.
so let's run this and see what happens
so one row is affected
let's
look at our table
and as you can see 1005 is now gone now
you have to be very careful when you use
the delete statement because once you
run it you cannot get that data back
there's no way to reverse a delete
statement so if i had gotten rid of this
where statement and i ran this it would
delete everything from the entire table
and you could not get that data back so
a little trick that i use before i
actually run a delete statement is i
make it a select statement because
you're going to select everything where
the employee id
is equal to let's just do 1004
and now when you run this you are going
to see exactly what you will be deleting
and now we know that angela martin that
entire row is going to be gone
if i hadn't done that and i just went
like this and i wrote delete and i only
had this running i would not know that
this information is going to be the only
one that's gone maybe i made a mistake
down here maybe i accidentally put
something in there that wasn't supposed
to be in there and now i'm deleting much
more than i thought i was actually going
to delete
so using the select statement can be a
very good safeguard against accidentally
deleting data that you do not want to
delete
now all aliasing really is is
temporarily changing the column name or
the table name in your script
and it's not really going to impact your
output at all aliasing is really used
for the readability of your script so
that if you hand this off to somebody or
somebody comes behind you and starts
working on this they can more easily
understand it and it may not sound super
useful especially for small scripts like
what we have on the screen
but when you start getting to larger
scripts where you have six seven or
eight joins and you're selecting 10
different column names it actually is
very useful and very important so let's
get into how that actually works and
then i'll have an example later of how
we can use aliasing with a little bit of
a larger query so in this table let's
select first name
and execute
what we want to do is just write as and
let's do fname
and all that's going to do is it's going
to rename this column from first name
which was originally named to fname
now you can use as but you can also just
get rid of that and do it exactly how i
have it and it's still going to work
perfectly you can either use the as or
you cannot use it i typically don't i
just put a space in between the actual
column and the alias now let's look at
an example of how this might actually be
useful so we have a first name and a
last name in this column so what we're
going to do is actually combine those so
let's do plus and let's add a space in
there and let's do a plus and let's do
last name so this is going to take the
first name add a space and then do the
last name and we're going to do that as
and let's do
full name
and let's execute
this so now we have a column called full
name which is our alias so we've
combined the first name and the last
name column into one single column and
we've renamed it full name if we had not
used this alias at all it would have
just said this which is no column name
at all we don't typically want that when
we have an output we want to give this
column a name so that somebody who's
actually looking at the script or who's
looking at the output of the script
actually understands what is contained
within this column so for that we're
just going to keep it
as full name now another time that
you're often going to use aliasing in
the select statement is when you're
using aggregate functions so in this
table we have age so let's pull that up
really quick
so we have age right here and let's
actually just do
the average age
and when we execute this we're going to
get no column name and 31 so we want to
do
is give it average age
and when we do that we now have a column
name and again you want to have a column
name in case someone comes up behind you
and is reading the script so they
understand what this column is being
used for now that we've looked at
aliasing column names let's look at
aliasing table names it basically is the
exact same thing
we're just going to write as and let's
do
demo for demographics
and let's do
demo dot and it's going to give us all
of our options and we'll do
employee id
so
when you alias in a table name when you
are selecting in the select statement
you actually need to preface your column
name with a table name or the table
alias dot and then employee id and this
is extremely important to do especially
when you have a lot of joins that you're
doing or you're selecting a lot of
columns when you have several joins
because it can get very very messy quick
so let's actually join this
to
employee salary
and let's do that on
demo dot
employee id is equal to
sale dot employee id
so now let's do demo dot employee id
comma
cell dot and let's do salary so looking
at the script now is very clean is very
easy to understand and that is what's so
important with aliasing
if for example we took this off
every time we wanted to reference this
table we would have to put the entire
table name and putting the entire table
name is correct it just is very
cumbersome and does not look clean at
all and so using something like demo as
an alias makes it a lot more easily
readable and a lot more manageable when
you're looking at it when you have a
very long script let's look at this
query where we're joined together three
separate tables and after each table we
have an alias for employee demographics
we have a fully salary we have b and
warehouse employee demographics we have
c now unfortunately i have seen a lot of
scripts that look exactly like this and
this is what you do not want to do you
do not want to use your aliasing to just
write an a a b or a c that is very
frowned upon when writing queries
because it really doesn't give any
context to what the table that you're
referencing is and it gets really
confusing as this query continues to
grow and as you add more columns to your
select statement it makes it more
difficult to understand where those
columns are coming from and so when i'm
reading that i say select a dot employee
id okay what's a a is employee
demographics so you really do not want
to do that now let's look at an example
of what it should look like so for
employee demographics instead of having
an alias of a i used demo for
demographics for employee salary i used
sal and for warehouse employee
demographics i used where now this is
not perfect by any means but in the
select statement if you're just glancing
at it you can easily understand which
columns are coming from which tables so
when i look at employee id i know that's
coming from employee demographics
because i have a demo as the alias so
it's a lot easier to understand and when
you hand this query off to somebody it
is going to be a lot easier for them to
read through it and understand where
those columns and those table names are
coming from and so they will appreciate
that in the long run so that is all i
got that is aliasing again not a super
tough subject but a really important one
to understand especially as you start
working in teams and as you start
creating more and more complex queries
you want to have it more organized and
more easily readable and so it may not
come into play with those really simple
queries but again as you build out those
more complex queries this becomes very
useful
now partition by is often compared to
the group by statement but the group by
statement is a little bit different the
group i statement is going to reduce the
number of rows in our output by actually
rolling them up and then calculating the
sums or averages for each group whereas
partition by actually divides the result
set into partitions and changes how the
window function is calculated and so the
partition by doesn't actually reduce the
number of rows returned in our output
let's get started to look at the actual
syntax of how to use partition by and
then we'll compare it to the group by
statement later just to see the
differences between the two we're going
to be using these two tables on our left
over here so i'm going to pull those up
really quick so let's run this and let's
look at the two
these two tables side by well one
underneath the other really quick so
what we're going to be using to
demonstrate the partition by is this
gender column as well as this salary
column and so we just need to join these
two tables together on the employee id
and then we'll go from there now i'm not
going to bore you with that i'm going to
skip ahead and we'll actually look at
how to use this partition by so i've
joined these two tables together and
this is our output but we don't want
every single column i'm going to start
selecting some of these columns and then
we'll start using this partition by and
see what the output looks like after
that all right so let's go right up here
let's choose the first name let's do the
last name
we'll do
gender
and let's do salary
and now we want to identify how many
male and female employees we actually
have and so we're going to say count
of gender
and it's going to be over
and now we're going to do our partition
by
and we're also going to partition that
by the gender
as
total
gender now i'm going to come back to why
we did each part but i want to see the
output first and then i'm going to come
back to why we wrote it this way
so let's just do this really quick
so it's going to be a little bit
different than what you typically would
expect in a group by statement the group
by's going to roll everything up and you
typically would have like a first name
last name and a group by statement
because it would be very hard to roll
all those things up into those
individual columns and to reduce the
number of columns that are in your
output and so in our output we can see
pam beasley she's a female she makes 36
000 as a salary and there are three
total women that work alongside her in
this employee demographics table and so
in our total gender column over here
this is where we use the partition by
and if we used a group by statement to
get this kind of information all we
would be able to do to get this
information in a group by statement is
say select gender count of gender and
then group by the gender down below
underneath the join
so because we're using the partition by
we're able to isolate just one column
that we want to perform our aggregate
function on and so we're able to add
things like the first name and last name
columns even though we aren't trying to
include that in any partition or group
by statement yet we're still able to add
the aggregate function to each
individual row while still maintaining
those other columns let's take this
entire query and let's basically just
transform it into a group by statement
and we'll see kind of what that looks
like and what the difference is
so all i'm going to do is get rid of all
this
i'm going to
copy all of this
and i'm going to say
group by
[Music]
and i'm going to do that because we have
to use all these columns in our group by
statement
so let's execute this
and as you can tell we are not able to
see the output for the aggregate
function that we were hoping for if we
wanted to get the same output that we
had before where we're showing three for
females and six for males what we'd have
to do is get rid of this first and last
name
and the salary
and do the same thing in the group by
statement
and so let me get rid of these really
quick
and run this
and so what the partition by is doing is
basically taking this query right here
and sticking it on one line in the
select statement and so i hope now you
can see how valuable the partition buy
can be if used correctly thank you guys
so much for watching i really appreciate
it if you like this video be sure to
like and subscribe below and i'll see in
the next video